[Música]
Bienvenidos a este programa especial de
ciencia y tecnología aquí en France 24
soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos la NASA y sus aliados
han logrado un nuevo hito en esta
carrera por la conquista espacial a
lanzar con éxito la primera versión de
su misión artemiso Artemisa despegó de
cabo Cañaveral El 16 de noviembre tras
cuatro aplazamientos
el hombre piso por primera vez la luna
en 1969 Neil Armstrong fue el afortunado
comandante de la misión Apolo 11
comandante del Apolo 17 en diciembre de
1972 tres años después fue el último
pero esta realidad podría cambiar en
2025 en la mitología griega artemis es
la hermana de Apolo y 50 años después de
la última misión Apolo ha despegado esta
primera versión considerada una prueba
al no tener tripulación pero sí tras
maniquíes equipados con más de 5000
sensores y 34 detectores de radiación
además viajan dos peluches uno de Snoopy
y otro de La Oveja Shaun son los
indicadores visuales de ingravidez
dentro de la nave se trata de un piloto
para analizar el nuevo cohete el sls el
más potente creado hasta el momento y la
cápsula orión todo ello para brindar la
mayor seguridad de los astronautas
futuros que se transporten en estas
misiones
estamos regresando a la luna no solo por
las ganas de ir a la luna sino para
aprender a vivir desarrollar aprender
Cómo vivir en la luna
para prepararnos en el camino de enviar
Humanos a marte
la luna está a solo unos días martes
está a meses de distancia
estamos entendiendo con el telescopio
James web lo grande y pasto que es este
universo
hay mucho por explorar y este es el
próximo inicio Esta es la generación
artemix
la primera misión tiene una duración de
25 días 11 horas y 36 minutos y hará un
sobrevuelo libre a 100 kilómetros de la
superficie lunar Para volver a la tierra
el 11 de diciembre y amerizar
controladamente en el océano Pacífico en
France 24 conversamos con Germán puerta
integrante de la asociación colombiana
de astronomía que nos dio más detalles
respecto a lo que se
Artemisa tiene
tres componentes principales este nuevo
sistema de lanzamiento con el cohete sls
que es 15% más poderoso que el Saturno 5
por fin vamos a ver un lanzamiento más
potente que los cohetes cambiaron las
misiones Apolo a la luna segundo
componente es establecer una base
espacial
orbitando alrededor de la luna se llama
Gateway es una base entonces importante
porque va a servir para estación de
atraque a las naves tripuladas o de
servicio y va a tener un sistema de
descenso
hacia la superficie de la luna y este es
el componente es establecer la base
lunar hay una conocimiento que no
teníamos antes con las misiones Apolo Y
es que ahora sabemos que hay agua en la
luna y muchísima agua en los caracteres
vecinos al Polo Sur
ayer en el interior de sus cráteres
donde jamás ha llegado la luz del sol
se encuentran como unas especies de
trampas frías millones de toneladas de
hielo de agua
y es allí en el vecindario de estos
caracteres en donde se va a establecer
la primera base tratar Y si todo sale
según lo planeado harto de mis dos
partirá en 2024 una misión tripulada que
hará un recorrido similar al de esta
versión todo ello para que en 2025 sea
lanzada artemis 3 que realmente espera
de volver a los humanos al satélite
terrestre por primera vez una mujer y
una afroamericano caminarán sobre la
luna también conversamos con Raúl joya
olarte ingeniero mecánico con
especialización en astronomía y le
preguntamos Por qué si los programas a
la luna causaron tanto interés nos
demoramos tanto tiempo en volver
que a lo largo de desde que se gestó la
famosa era espacial la posición
imaginario de política y de poderío de
los Estados Unidos frente al mundo se
dejó sentado de hecho pues quedaron
algunos cohetes que podían haber
regresado a los 70s a la superficie
lunar no se hicieron quedaron aquí
parqueados y en este momento otras
agencias y países como la china están
demostrando que pueden regresar a la
luna y colocar
progresos que puedan poner en duda el
desarrollo y el poderío político de los
Estados Unidos es una cuestión que
nuevamente está tomando aparte de los
científicos vendrán tema político de
poder tenemos que decir que artemis es
un trabajo conjunto de la NASA y otras
agencias espaciales una misión calculada
de forma milimétrica No solo por el
costo que representa sino también porque
muchos de los componentes y algunas
materias primas no habían sido probadas
antes fuera de nuestro planeta
el caso del sls el sistema de
lanzamiento espacial un cohete 15% más
poderoso que el Saturno 5 que llegó a
las misiones Apolo y transportó hasta la
órbita el Sky y la la primera estación
espacial estadounidense Asimismo está la
cápsula orión fruto del trabajo de unas
30.000 personas justamente la agencia
espacial europea es la responsable del
módulo de servicio que proporciona
propulsión energía agua oxígeno y
nitrógeno Además del sistema de
temperatura
la habilidad clave que se está probando
en la misión artemis es la cobertura
térmica en la cápsula orión para cuando
reingrece a la atmósfera terrestre como
viene de la luna lleva una velocidad
mucho más alta que la de las misiones
orbitales que hemos visto en la última
década y probar esa Capa termoprotectora
en la cápsula orión es uno de los
principales criterios para determinar el
éxito de la misión artemis 1
es imposible no hacer comparaciones
sobre el programa Apolo y el primero
funcionó más como una ventana de
exploración de la luna con
investigaciones sobre la superficie y la
órbita del satélite artemis como lo han
dicho los expertos Busca que los humanos
vuelvan a la luna Pero esta vez para
quedarse
volver a la luna para ayudar a entender
Cómo mantener humanos vivos en espacios
espaciales durante largos periodos
si se compara con el programa Apolo sí
se centraba en la exploración lunar pero
durante estancias muy cortas periodos de
una a dos semanas para las misiones
artemis Se buscan periodos más largos de
exploración como base para la
exploración de otras partes del sistema
solar como Martín para muchas personas
las misiones espaciales son consideradas
una pérdida de tiempo y dinero no
obstante la exploración y determinar las
condiciones para una posible Estancia
prolongada en la luna y posteriormente
en otros planetas son una parte
fundamental de la actual carrera
espacial en la que participan Estados
Unidos china Europa Canadá Israel y
varios otros países Además está la
participación de empresas privadas como
spacex y boing algo que genera un
impulso fundamental que puede acelerar
procesos para los expertos continuar con
la exploración espacial constituye un
paso clave en la evolución de la
humanidad
desde que el ser humano ya tiene uso de
razón sobre la superficie de este
planeta siempre ha buscado la forma de
tener una vida más cómoda
de poder subsistir frente a las otras
especies y el ser humano desde que ya
trabajo por ejemplo la rueda Pues llega
a conquistar el planeta de la superficie
diríamos normales de hoy en día pero el
hecho de estar el espacio afuera y no
poder conocerlo Es algo que no ha
permitido que se frene la investigación
podemos decir que si tenemos muchas
necesidades del planeta pero los grandes
equipos de personas que invierten plata
en este campo muchas veces toda esa
investigación se retorna En beneficio de
la humanidad en temas de Medicina más de
seguridad en tiendas de prevención de
desastres entonces son cosas que están
recuperándose Y reinvirtiéndose en el
día a día del vivir de nosotros con este
tema redes sociales las comunicaciones
tan eficientes que tenemos hoy en día
están poniendo a volar la mente de
muchas personas en cualquier ámbito
profesión u oficio y el tema espacial se
va a volver a inyectar en todos los
trabajos y las actividades del ser
humano porque van a estar mirando hacia
arriba es decir la gente está
encontrándole sentido a que si se puede
aplicar algo al espacio pero con una un
beneficio para la humanidad va a ser muy
bueno y yo creo que esta nueva
generación lo va a tomar por ese lado
los expertos también dejan Claro que así
como las misiones Apolo inspiraron a
millones de personas otro de los logros
de artemis era estimular el interés por
el espacio y permitir que toda una nueva
generación se maravilla con todo lo que
las nuevas tecnologías nos están
permitiendo conocer
en este momento tuyo estamos conversando
gracias a la era del espacio si no fuera
por ese extraordinario esfuerzo que se
realizó para llegar a la luna Entonces
no sé No tendríamos esta modernidad no
habría internet y celulares No ni
satélites ni Comunicaciones y muchas de
los elementos que estás usando aquí en
tu oficina o en el lugar o en el
automóvil tienen directamente era el
espacio aplicaciones derivadas de la
edad del espacio no te imaginas la
cantidad de jóvenes y niños que se están
inspirando se van a inspirar en
estos programas para hacer una nueva
oleada de intereses en carrera
científicas y tecnológicas Pues con toda
esta inspiración espacial llegamos al
final de este programa a nuestros
expertos Les agradecemos su
participación y su tiempo y a ustedes su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más en France 24 y France 24
[Música]